the nebia by moan quattro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 percent as much water but with a
super high pressure spray click the link
below and use the code pacman for 10
off all nebia products
we're already seeing and we're going to
continue to see
massive increase in gas prices and this
is going to be dramatically accelerated
because the united states will announce
today by the time you watch today's show
listen to today's podcast it may already
have been announced the u.s will ban oil
from russia and the european union plans
to reduce by two-thirds the amount of
oil purchased from russia we are already
at record high gas prices and this is
only going to get worse and i'm going to
talk about all aspects of this i'll talk
about the political
i will talk about the technological the
climate change component and the
economic but let's start with the big
news today the u.s is expected today to
announce a ban on russian oil
the white house updated president joe
biden's schedule to include an
announcement of additional steps the us
will take to hold russia accountable for
its uh war on ukraine
those remarks will be delivered at the
white house today and the expectation is
a ban on imports of russian oil
which would cut about eight percent of
america's annual supply now i want to
remind everybody
we hear this talking point from the
right we were energy independent under
trump and now we no longer are the truth
is that in the last couple years of
trump as well as last year under joe
biden the u.s produced as much oil as it
used but that doesn't mean we only use
our own oil some of the oil we we
produce we export and we also import so
even though total production and
consumption were roughly equal the last
couple years of trump and biden that is
true
but also oil is imported from russia
regularly it's about eight percent of
american oil consumption
and that is going to stop that has
already caused oil prices to spike
in addition the european union is
pledging to cut russian gas imports by 2
3. did i say oil before i meant to say
gas the eu is pledging to cut russian
gas imports by two-thirds before the end
of the year
and that will also have an uh impact on
energy prices gas rather than oil
on top of this
shell will no longer buy russian oil
nor russian gas
shell said it is breaking completely
with russia's giant energy industry
halting all purchases of russian crude
oil immediately and shutting service
stations in the country the uk-based
company last week announced it was
dumping investments in russia
said it is abandoning all trade in
russian fossil fuels to align with
government guidance
russia is warning of 300 oil
and threatening to cut off european gas
if the west band's energy imports
and now europe is saying well we're
cutting down by two-thirds anyway so
russia looking to escalate and threaten
and believe me i mean three
i'm against the use of fossil fuels i
believe our transition to renewables has
been pathetically slow and hindered by
bad or lack of policy in large oil
consuming western nations all of it and
i can't ignore
that 300 oil
and what it would do to gas prices and
home heating gasoline prices and home
heating
would be devastating to anyone who is in
a financially precarious or or even
you know balanced but not exactly a
surplus economic situation and we're
going to talk about that now we are
already seeing we are already seeing
record gas prices the average is now
right around 419 per gallon and if you
go back you know over the last 10 years
gas got close to four about 394 back in
2012
about 369 in 2014 this is the highest
that gas prices have been in 10 years so
where do we even start
first and foremost we have to remember
the political
how can american presidents impact gas
prices gas prices are up globally and
there are lots of people who just want
to blame joe biden this is very stupid
now fact check me on this
i don't play politics with gas prices
when gas prices are low under a democrat
i say presidents have very little to do
with gas prices when gas prices are low
under a republican i say presidents have
very little to do when gas is high under
a republican or a democratic president i
say presidents don't have very much to
do with gas prices fact check me on it
this is a very dumb political football
what can presidents do to impact gas
prices okay
one an american president can say we're
going to war
against an oil producing country usually
that raises gas prices uh when we go to
war with a country that produces oil
it's
potentially going to disrupt the supply
so when an american president says let's
invade like for example you know the
first iraq war
prices tend to go up number two
a president can change gasoline taxes
raise or lower and they can't
unilaterally do it but a president can
advocate for that
and if gas taxes go up then gas prices
go up and okay so that's number two and
then number three and this is the most
commonly discussed one there's this
thing called the strategic petroleum
reserve
and a president can
release oil
from the strategic petroleum reserve
which will
cause a small decrease in the price of
oil and eventually gas
or or it will slow down the increase if
gas prices are increasing really quickly
so presidents can do very very little
and this is global it's happening
everywhere so if your priority is
blaming biden
i don't even want to hear from you
because it's just not
even substantive
the more pressing question is number one
um this again exposes how
humiliatingly
woefully
behind we have been on getting off of
oil now i know it's like oh you're going
to do that you're going to do you're
going to be that guy david i understand
that transitioning off of oil takes time
transitioning off of natural gas takes
time putting solar panels on roofs
and having electric heating and cooking
and electric cars so that you get off
fossil fuels other than for the
production of all of the stuff that
you're using i get that that takes time
but we also need to remember that we
didn't make much progress under obama we
didn't make almost any progress under
trump
we continue to have completely
inaccurate gas prices in other words our
gas prices don't even come close to
reflecting
the true cost of gasoline
on the environment and on the economy
and on society so it we're we're just
it's been pathetic
and i also understand how if you're a
family that like 40
of families in the united states
can't meet an unexpected
400 expense without
taking down on debt putting a credit
card or whatever
i understand that if gas prices go up
to five six dollars a gallon which 520
is one of the numbers that's being
thrown around average gallon could go to
520
um and you need heating oil to heat your
home because you don't have one of these
new fancy electric heat pumps and solar
panels and all you're still paying for
oil
um i get how you'll probably end up
going into debt just to fuel your car
and heat your home so we can hold both
at the same time but let's at least be
accurate in terms of uh uh who is to
blame for this
and the real role of presidents and once
the announcement is made and more
accurate forecasts are made
we will follow that up
i am so glad to have the opportunity
today
to uh
i guess bring you more evidence that my
instinct yesterday when we looked at
clips of donald trump's former attorney
general william barr saying trump's
election lies were bs and whatever it
doesn't make barr a good guy it doesn't
even make him a sensible guy
and the day after
these clips went viral of william barr
saying trump brought in a clown show of
lawyers after the election all of this
stuff
when pressed william barr still says
i'd vote for trump over a democrat if he
ran in 2024. this is exactly what i was
talking about yesterday bill barr after
saying
trump lied about the election
he
uh incited the attack on january 6th etc
etc
he told savannah guthrie yesterday well
if it's trump versus a democrat of
course i'm going to vote for trump
because democrats are really really bad
this is why i say
these are not good people these people
are not our friends or any of it billbar
wants to sell books that's all that's
going on take a listen
you say in your book it's time for the
party to move on from trump liz cheney
has said he is not fit to serve and
should not be ever near the oval office
again do you agree with that
well i certainly
have made it clear i don't think he
should be our nominee and i'm going to
you know support somebody else for the
nomination but if he is the nominee and
you have your choices
donald trump or whoever's running on the
democratic side would you vote for him
uh
because i believe that the the greatest
threat to the country is the progressive
agenda being pushed by the democratic
party it's inconceivable to me that i
wouldn't vote for the republican nominee
so
even if he lied about the election and
threatened democracy as you write in
your book
well it's better than a democrat it's
hard to project what the facts are going
to turn out to be three years hence but
as of now it's hard for me to conceive
that i wouldn't vote for
even though he's a threat to democracy
a threat to our country
incited a riot
lied about who won the election
brought out a clown show of lawyers
i mean listen progressives are really
the threat
this is why these people are so
dangerous guys and this is why i told
you he stumbled across some small
factoid some small element of truth
but this is not a this is not a good guy
and it's the same thing with liz cheney
at the end of the day liz cheney maybe
wouldn't vote for trump against a a
democratic nominee
but she still did vote with trump
something like 88 percent of the time
when trump was president just as a
reminder here's what william barr said
about trump yesterday but remember
he he'd still vote for trump over a
democrat and i told him that all this
stuff was bull
and
about election fraud
and uh
it was wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team was
and he started asking me about different
theories and i had the answers i was
able to tell him this is wrong because
of this you're trying to set him
straight yes and and and you know he
listened
he he he was obviously getting very
angry about this i said okay well look i
understand you're upset with me
and i'm perfectly happy to
tender my resignation and then boom he
slaps the desk he slapped the desk and
he said accepted
accept it
and then boom he slapped it again accept
it
go home don't go back to your office go
home
so uh william barr saying that william
barr also referring to all those wacky
lawyers that trump hired to try to flip
the election as a clown show
and
about election fraud
and
it was wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team was
and then he also told trump what he
thought of his legal team
not a lot
i said the reason you are where you are
is because you wheeled out a clown show
of lawyers
a clown show yeah clown car or something
like that i said yeah so uh anyway he'd
still vote for trump if there's a
democrat
i mean he says this guy's not fit to
serve he's a threat to the country
terrible for democracy all this stuff
well but no i mean listen i'm not going
to vote for joe biden completely you
know innocuous milktoast democrat who
you know will be lucky to have major
accomplishments that that change
american society or the economy in any
serious way it's actually almost worse
that you know there's the people who
think trump's great
it's like okay well i disagree with you
uh and i i would i would have that
argument with you
but these people
realize trump is nuts a threat to
democracy
unfit to serve and they still say well
if it's joe biden or commell i mean i
just can't imagine i would ever vote for
a democrat it's completely and totally
bonkers and this is exactly what i was
talking about when i was saying this guy
wants to sell a book that's all he wants
to do send me your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan quattro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving showerhead starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just a hundred and
nineteen dollars but nebia is giving you
ten percent off when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video the david
pakman show depends on your support to
do what we do you can sign up on our
website
joinpackman.com get a membership you'll
get the daily bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and you'll get the show
every day not only without commercials
you'll get it five to six hours before
everybody else there's some really great
perks to being a member and you can sign
up at joinpackman.com
also want to mention we have a new
initiative if you were already a content
creator we are going to be doing a sort
of group coaching thing where i will
work with four or five hand-picked
content creators to help grow your
platform the only requirement is you
must already be regularly creating
content on one of the major platforms
and you have to apply
at davidpakman.com coaching i mentioned
yesterday four or five times
davidpakman.com coaching a bunch of
people emailed me saying david i'd like
to apply do not email me if you email
you it it's going guy i i hate to say it
the instruct by virtue of not being able
to follow the instructions it's already
bad okay davidpakman.com
coaching no need to email if you're
interested
davidpakman.comcoaching and the
information is there you can apply it's
going to be a cool new thing
hoping to grow some other content
creators
let's look at some stunning clips you
may have heard or you may not that the
us trucker convoy advocating for freedom
from
something uh mandates i guess that
mostly don't exist or i don't know the
u.s trucker convoy is demanding their
freedom they have been oppressed by
tyranny and different things they've
started to get close to washington dc
and some interviews have now been done
with them
and it it seems like a skit
here are the good liars the good liars
who do they do this really really well
interviewing one trucker yesterday
and she is most concerned that they want
to
digitize
excuse me i i can't
i can't even say the word
digitize
us like you know how you would tile a
shower
and digitize so it's digitized
she doesn't want to be digitized
wow take a look are you really concerned
about right now
i don't want them to digitize
you don't want them what it's a
digitalist
i don't want to take medicine that'll
hurt people what was the what was the
word you used though i haven't heard
that digital
digital
digital
and what what does that mean
they're trying to
they're trying to make us robots they're
trying to make it where we have no
choice and nothing to where they control
maybe by digitize she means like made
into an android or something oh they can
control us from what they put in our
bodies
and eventually we'll we'll actually be
robots
according to what they're saying not
robots but according to what they've
already got a
full
man-made working female robot maybe i
guess she's talking about
like those sex robots that recently made
news i don't even know but how how wild
is that guys like how much of this
entire trucker convoy fiasco
is just the result of bad education and
confused people i mean this woman seems
to not have any idea why she's there
she's there because they want to
digitize us i mean it's is it is it that
you know we talk about
well you know there's sort of like these
misunderstandings about what liberty and
freedom are and people want freedoms
absent responsibilities and it's like
are we just doing too much and it's just
like they want to digitize us it's just
confusion and bad education is it just
that simple um here's another interview
with some uh
truckers i guess is what we're calling
them um
and the these folks want uh they believe
the russian invasion might be fake it's
just it's not really going on i guess
easily fake a war if they wanted to all
they would do is just like film a few
things are you aware that the majority
of the pictures that they've been
showing regarding the alleged war in
ukraine are from prior conflicts and are
unrelated to ukraine yeah that's what i
was saying we shouldn't have anything to
do with it at all
let them figure out their own mess the
very patriotic honking in the background
as you can hear state
has always made putin to look like the
bad guy
but he's a good guy freedom
okay so um the war is fake also that's
another you know pretty big brain take
and then um here's one more clip of a
guy wearing
i guess some kind of uh
head
it's almost like a chain link armor i'm
sure these things have specific names
but i don't know them take a listen to
this guy
is this a crusade
you know it's a crusade in the fact that
people have to
fight the evil in the world man and the
evil is uh well you're heading down to
the evil
in the in the world and people have to
band together and fight on the side of
the lord
you know god wills it man
so anyway so that guy thinks that
they're basically doing i guess they're
i guess god wants there to be
a convoy
and they are there doing their thing uh
now one other thing just that this might
be of interest they
i i actually this is actually sort of
smart like they're realizing that if
they go into dc they
they might actually get arrested
blocking traffic different things so one
of their i guess leaders is framing it
as they're trying to sort of like goad
us into going to dc to then arrest us or
something take a listen
i am fearful
brian
and the organizers are fearful of them
trying to do to us what they did to
those involved in january 6th
it is our belief that they will
try to do that
so with that said
we are making
diplomatic
moves
that means that we're not
that means
at this time meaning today
and tomorrow
we are not
and will not
go into dc proper
so that was disappointing to some of the
convoy people but others realize you
know they're trying to set us up like
they set up the rioters and we're not
going into dc basically the entire thing
has fallen flat and the interviews with
the vast majority of the folks are
indistinguishable from what would be a
saturday night live skit when saturday
night live was at its funniest
um okay this your i i hope that people
understand the multiple layers of this
clip that i'm gonna play for you um some
of you i know follow ufc ultimate
fighting championship which is a an mma
league a mixed martial arts league or
tournament i don't know if they call
themselves a league or you know event
organizing organization um one of those
fighters a guy named bryce mitchell
delivered a completely delusional
right-wing rant the other day
and
we're gonna look at the rant because the
rant itself is totally wacky but the
other thing that i want to mention is
donald trump jr
uh retweeted it and said i'm with him
now i just want to remind you guys of
the absurdity of all of these
right-wingers who say athletes should
just be athletes shut up and dribble
this type of thing when they don't like
lebron james's activism or they don't
like colin kaepernick or
an olympic athlete or whatever making a
political point that they don't like
they say these you got to keep this
stuff these are just athletes at the end
of the day they should just be doing
their sport
but when you see a guy like bryce
mitchell deliver a delusional right-wing
rant don jr all of a sudden loves it now
there are so many
prototypical fallacies and red herrings
here
that it's it's like a master class in
lack of critical thinking so let's just
start and then we'll we'll analyze as we
go well i just wanted to get your
thoughts on the whole russia and ukraine
situation
you know um
here's my first starters i'm not going
nowhere to fight none of these wars for
these politicians i'm staying at home
and when the war comes to arkansas i
will dig my boots in the ground and i
will die for everything i love okay now
that's totally fine i'm actually fine
with that and but now remember joe biden
has said he's not sending troops to
ukraine anyway also the idea that people
are going to invade arkansas i mean i'm
not making fun of arkansas but arkans if
he's like well i'm from arkansas i'm
just here to defend arkansas it's
unlikely just statistically when you
consider what are the economic centers
etc that arkansas is going to be the
front line but that doesn't matter so
far fine he's not going to get involved
he doesn't want to fight the war fight
i'm with you i will not retreat okay
this country's invaded and
everybody's saying well we gotta we
gotta evacuate we gotta leave we got i
will not i will dig my boots in the
arkansas soil and i will fight for the
people that i love for the land that i
love and the way life that i love but
i'm not going overseas to fight
i don't know what's going on to be
honest brother i really okay so he
admits he doesn't know what's going on
good that good
there's so much stuff and i don't think
nobody knows what's going on oh but okay
so now is where we start to get to this
trope
i don't think anyone knows what's going
on it's so complicated
nobody can know what's going on and this
is a typical thing that you hear
from i mean listen we've seen these
vaccines i mean syringes
mrna uh a polyethylene glycol the virus
its sequence but from a lab or not i
don't think anyone really understands it
well no no no
you might not understand it but people
do understand so look there's this
invisible air that we breathe but it's
got oxygen in it nitrogen co2 i don't
think anyone really understands which of
these elements do we really need to
survive no actually we do know that
we actually you might not know it so
this is where it starts to get a little
bit fallacious and then
so remember he said he doesn't know
what's going on and nobody knows what's
going on let's continue there's been so
much political corruption in that area
you got biden and his son making a [ __ ]
ton of money well wait hold on a second
wait a second
if you don't know what's going on
and you just aren't sure of what's
happening
then why are you repeating
right wing conspiracies about joe biden
personally making money from from the so
it sounds like now you're asserting you
do know what's going on
off of uh and using our tax dollars to
bribe
their people that's treasonous in my
opinion
so he goes from
i don't know what's going on and i don't
want to get involved
to biden
committed treason
by using u.s tax dollars to bribe
someone
wait a second i thought you said you
didn't know what was going on bryce
uh so you got hunter biden and his son
using our tax dollars hey if if by the
way hunter biden's son i'm guessing he
means joe biden he doesn't even know the
talking points hunter i didn't even this
is the does hunter biden even have a son
i guess he does i don't i don't i mean
he's such a non-factor i don't even know
whether hunter biden has kids but i've
certainly never heard that they're
involved in the conspiracy ukrainian
government if you don't do this we're
taking your tax dollars he shouldn't be
giving our tax dollars to that country
anyway now what's really funny is
if you want to by the way for a guy who
doesn't know anything surely expressing
a lot of opinions if what's funny about
this is
if if you don't think
things should be held over the head of
ukraine
trump
wanted to withhold military aid until
such time that ukraine got him dirt on
biden and thanks to colonel vinman and
others trump ultimately had to release
the military aid to ukraine this guy's
criticism which he claims i don't know
anything and now he's making about it
actually applies to trump think about
how backwards everything is here
veterans out here sleeping on the street
and you're gonna give our freaking tax
dollars to these ukrainians and all i'd
rather i don't know what's going on over
there but i'm not going over there and
fighting and god bless anybody that's
over there's fighting and i hope that
this just gets solved and man i don't
like war
you know what i mean i don't want people
dying and all that stuff i don't want to
be but i don't know what's going on
there's so much stuff that i think
that's corrupted that we just don't know
what for a guy who says i don't know and
we don't know he sure has a whole hell
of a lot of opinions and of course he
was spreading all sorts of
misinformation here and then he was
called out for it and then he was his
reaction to uh to that dude
you were recently on the mma hour what
was the reception to that interview like
oh i'm sorry this is him reacting to uh
from what he said on the mma hour okay
all the aerial hawaii's yeah well he
kind of he didn't completely censor me
but he put that i was spreading
misinformation and
um
i don't know you know i thought
i said a lot of true stuff and
but
it's open to a debate and
you know um
i love the second amendment and i love
the first and you know why we have the
first because we have the second yeah
and so that's a classic uh classic gun
gun uh gun person uh cl claim um
when someone writes an article saying
you spread misinformation uh about what
you said on a podcast the first
amendment just isn't a factor it just
has nothing to do with government
censorship of speech and so you know my
view is i don't have any particular
there some people say athletes should
talk about politics and others say they
shouldn't the equivalent of shut up and
dribble
i think anyone should say what's on
their mind in whatever venue they deem
appropriate and if people don't like it
they can respond to that and say i'm not
going to patronize this or that or i'm
not going to pay for tickets to see
whatever
but
whatever you say is subject to review
and to criticism and i've heard
interesting things said by athletes
before what this guy is saying is just
utter and complete nonsense and uh he's
welcome on the program anytime to
discuss any of these uh topics we'll
have the clip on instagram at david
pakman's show if you're just listening
today it is worth watching it rather
than just listening
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
today i'm going to be speaking with
alexandra hudson who's an award-winning
journalist author and speaker as well as
the founder of civic renaissance her new
book is against politeness why
politeness failed america and how
civility can save it it's so great
having you on i really appreciate it
thanks david for having me
so i mean i think to start with we
should talk about the difference between
politeness and civility there's so much
discussion particularly in modern
politics about
many people aren't civil or can we
continue to be civil
versus politeness which which is really
something different so maybe let's start
there like what are these two different
concepts
it's a it's a good question that's
that's the core thesis of of my
forthcoming book that there is this
difference but i think a lot of people
today fail to recognize there's a
difference we use these two terms
civility and politeness interchangeably
and that makes it difficult to think
okay what do we want less of in society
and what do we want more of um because
people today they either long for more
civility more politeness they long for
these days of gentility and chivalry and
uh thinks society's going to hell in a
handbasket or they want less of
plainness they think that it's uh they
want they think it's civility is a tool
of of white supremacy a tool of social
oppression a tool of social injustice so
i argue that by making this distinction
we can again have more clarity about
what we're talking about we want what we
want so i argue that
politeness is a technique it's manners
it's the superficial expression of you
know social norms and etiquette
um civility by contrast is a disposition
it's a way of looking at others and the
world and seeing other people as human
beings just like us with equal moral
worth and with beings with dignity and
worth and worthy of respect and the
etymology of these two terms supports
that distinction the the root word uh
politeness is the latin word poliere
which means to smooth or polish and
that's what politeness does again it
focuses on the external um
whereas civility that the latin root is
kivitos or kivis which is city or
citizen and and civility connotes the
the conduct befitting a member of the
city or a citizen of the duties of
citizenship so i think it's important to
make these this distinction to know you
know what do we want more of and what do
we want less of in society for many
people they might be thinking about
these concepts in the context of
conversations they have with you know
their uncle at thanksgiving or whatever
the case may be can you kind of apply
this
to
such interpersonal conversations and
give us examples of of how civility and
politeness
can overlap but also one can exist
absent the other and kind of what that
would look like in human interaction
absolutely i'm of the mind that
civility is actually
the truly respectful way of engaging
with others because seeing people as
human beings first with equal moral
worth so whereas politeness would want
to smooth over differences um civility
says i respect you enough david to tell
you when i think you're terribly wrong
on a subject i'm not going to patronize
you and just smile when i think that
you're incorrect i'm gonna tell you what
i think that's that truly respectful
thing to do however and again that's
what a democracy requires it requires
having being able to have robust honest
discourse and not just um you know
suppressing discussion or papering over
important differences however i will
note that not all
contexts in life are the same you know
having a debate in a college classroom
or on the floors of of congress is
different than having a dinner with your
family member and i'm a firm believer
that
um politics has taken too much of our
consciousness and our psychiatrist is
too much a part of our lives and there
are way more important things in
politics such as relationships with
family members and i i don't think that
you have to fight to death on every
single political issue it's it's too
easy to let political issues come
between relationships and family family
family relationships these days and so i
think it's perfectly fine to say you
know what we're not going to talk about
xyz issue we're not going to talk about
politics at all because because we're
going to talk about other things you
know our kids or you know our lives
because this relationship matters more
than focusing on you know the sore spots
the areas of disagreement that may not
be reconcilable right now yeah sometimes
viewers will call me and they'll say hey
you know like for example a left-wing
viewer will call and say
when i go back to
wherever during college break you know
my parents have turned into the opposite
of what i am they watch fox news all day
and they think joe biden lost and they
think the vaccines turn you into a
turtle and you know all these different
things um how can i
change their mind
and
and my answer always is well what what
are you willing to allow to happen to
your relationship with them because i
can i could answer in terms of how minds
are sometimes changed but part of it is
are you willing to not have a
relationship with them anymore or you
need to figure that out first so to
speak and it seems that that
is missing sometimes from just figuring
out how can i have my ideas win over
someone someone else's and i think
that's reflective of this mentality in
our political discourse today where it's
all zero sum it's like i have to win and
it's and i'm gonna win at all costs it's
like you know scorched earth policy and
you can't take that logic and apply it
to our relationships and our family and
our family context um hey i don't think
that's the right thing to do and and b
uh that's not the right thing to do
generally you can't have a democracy
with that sort of skirt scorched earth
zero some uh mindset that's part of my
part the conclusion of my book argues
that again we have we suffer from a
crisis of misplaced meaning in our
society today where these traditional
touchstones family civil society church
these are all kind of on the rescindent
and in recent years and and politics has
become the place where we derive our
meaning from which is why which is why
every political issue it like cuts us to
our core if someone disagrees with us
it's like we're being personally
assaulted and we go into fight or flight
mode as opposed to if we had these other
derived our meeting from other places we
could have kind of the equanimity of
spirit to be able to have these
difficult conversations but we we've
allowed politics to matter too much to
us which is why it's difficult to have
these conversations well before we move
on to the more like governmental level
application of this to keep it at the
personal a little bit there are no doubt
people who will hear this conversation
and they'll say well you know guys
alexander david uh uh there are
circumstances where it's not that i'm
looking for a fight but i cannot be
civil nor polite uh with people who for
example if i were gay and i know that
there i'm around people whether it's
parents or co-workers or whatever who
quite literally believe that i'm going
to hell i'm an evil person or whatever
something so fundamental to what i am
and who i am it's not that i'm trying to
make political disagreements the
forefront but
i can't be civil with someone who sees
me in that way it's very easy to say
let's not make it all about politics we
don't have but when it's something so
core to who i am
i can't be civil i can't be polite it's
not possible
there's validity to that as well isn't
there of course and i absolutely
empathize with that position i would
however point uh people of that mindset
to a really powerful example of someone
who lives out lives out
decency with people
that that that he disagrees with to say
the least that the jazz uh uh uh
musician daryl davis if you haven't
heard of him he's been on the show yeah
awesome yeah exactly his his story is
incredible where he he he makes um you
know makes it his personal mission in
life to win over white supremacists who
literally think he's a sub-human and he
does it through conversation and
kindness and relationship no one's ever
been persuaded to change their mind
about anything by being insulted and
like hit over the head with rationality
and arguments and he really embodies the
ethos of saying you know i'm going to
see the personhood past the bigotry um
and i'm going to try and reach that and
and focus on what we have in common and
he's changed a lot of hearts and minds
that way that's a really powerful
example for each of us
yeah what he does is is really
incredible um when it comes to national
and world level politics are there some
examples of of when politeness led to
bad outcomes or results that we could
talk through
well politeness across history has been
this tool of division it's been it's
been a way of signifying the in-group
and the out-group both country both
within between countries and within a
given
society it's been a way for uh people to
feel superior to others
um uh in ancient greece for example um
they anyone who didn't speak greek and
have the manners of of greek people were
we're called barbarians that's where we
get our word uh barbarian from it's when
someone it means someone who basically
doesn't speak greek and and for the
greeks they didn't leave it as okay they
just speak a different language and they
have different manners than us for them
they said okay they're different from us
therefore they're morally inferior and
they're less like they're lesser than us
and that logic that kind of thinking is
not unique to the ancient greeks we see
that all across culture all across
history um and even through to today in
the american gildan age for example
there's a fabulous new hbo show called
the gilded age that i'm loving right now
every monday night and that's a great
example of of how manners and and social
norms and politeness was weaponized to
keep the the nouveau reese the parva
news the rockefellers and the carnegies
they were the new voge they're the names
that we remember now but they were the
out group they were the ones that uh the
old money and society wanted to keep out
and so emily emily vanderbilt speak a
big um tome and on etiquette and emily
post as well those are all etiquette
books on you know handbooks for how to
be a social elite that actually um the
middle class and immigrants who came to
america started reading and saying oh my
gosh this is what it means to be an
american and they kind of helped them
assimilate it was kind of a shorthand
for how to how to do this thing called
life together so what originally started
as this project of exclusion ended up
being a way to invite and welcome the
newcomer into society yeah that's
interesting i've heard from people who
did not grow up necessarily with parents
that were able to inform them of of a
lot of kind of social norms and
etiquette stuff talk about i got into
college and then the job fairs and and
they realized at a certain point when
they would get to either these group
interviews or different things it wasn't
that they were
less able or knowledgeable when it came
to the subject matter but they realized
they didn't know all the social norms
even when things things as simple as
when everybody sits at a table to a meal
and there's sort of like a pecking order
in terms of like were the people doing
the hiring were the people they and they
knew they were at a disadvantage
specifically for those reasons
absolutely i think too often we assume
we know someone's character you know
their their inner state by the the
shorthand by manners whether they know
which fork to use and again this is how
the norms of politeness have been
weaponized across human history and part
of my argument with my for my book is is
we need to
focus less on those the trimmings you
know to focus less on the etiquette more
on the timeless principles of civility
that have served us well in this project
of human community across time and place
i argue that you know civility is not a
new problem it's not an america problem
it's not a now problem it is a human
problem which is why every single
society without fail across history has
had etiquette books that's a whole genre
and they've had social norms that help
us do this thing called life together
it's hard society and civilization is
fragile and it takes work and if we're
not all doing this together not we're
not all part of this you know thing
called society together um it's going to
fall apart and we we we've seen like we
we have um we're watching you know
civilization fall apart in the ukraine
right now we like war war is is very
much a part of um of our world today and
uh we can't take that for granted we
have to remember the role that we each
have in supporting this this thing
called a free society this thing called
a democracy and this thing called human
community hey when it comes to someone
like donald trump you know the the
making fun of a disabled reporter and
the thing rosie o'donnell i don't
remember as a dog or as fat or whatever
you know all the coarse language and all
that stuff
did did trump change expectations of
politeness or civility in politics
i think that's an interesting question
there is no doubt that um he he did
course in our public discourse in a lot
of ways um but his his
two things i think his
um the crassness of his language the
candor i think a lot of people saw that
as truth-telling that was the you know
people saw that as okay he's being
honest and civil people are sick of the
politeness the veneer the the political
correctness people are sick of being
suppressed and and you know the language
policing that was going on he cut
through the hypocrisy of all that and i
think that appealed to a lot of people
which is um kind of why i make the
argument that we need to care less about
the form care less about the the
politeness and more about civility the
honest truth telling that we need for
democracy so i think he tapped into a
really important insight that people
have been sensing and intuiting for a
really long time but secondly it is
really important that to realize that
donald trump did not create our
stability problem again this is not an a
new problem not an america problem this
is a human problem it's been a challenge
to human community so i i argue in my
book that as human beings we are
profoundly social we thrive we become
fully human in community but we're also
profoundly selfish and self-interested
we aim to meet our needs uh before
others we're just biologically morally
driven that way and and those two things
are always intention they always have
been and always will be so there's
there's never going to be a permanent
solution um to the civility challenge uh
in our world today and there never has
been but but what we can do is look to
the wisdom of the past look to how
thoughtful people have have um have have
advised that we overcome this tension
before it and help us live live well
together
the forthcoming book is against
politeness why politeness failed america
and how civility can save it we've been
speaking with the author alexandra
hudson an award-winning award-winning
journalist author and speaker really
appreciate your time and your insights
today thanks so much for having me david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show many of you have been
uh emailing me saying david you're on
rumble the right wing sort of clone of
youtube are you going to get on truth
social trump's right-wing clone of
twitter and the answer is i've actually
tried but
i'm unable to get on
and uh many questions as to why
yet another one of these right-wing app
launches has gone horribly wrong and
indeed there are now reports that donald
trump is completely furious about the
failure of this completely farcical
social media app uh the daily beast is
reporting
that um donald trump is just going
completely bonkers um as donald trump
weighs another run for the white house
he embarked on a new business
opportunity which is truth social and
it's looking like an embarrassing dud in
recent weeks sources have heard the
former president on the phone
swearing gratuitously and asking things
like what the f is going on
he's repeatedly groused about the
negative press and the less than stellar
optics of the rollout these sources said
and he's demanded to know why more
people aren't using it why the app isn't
swiftly dominating the competition now i
think there's there's actually two parts
to this there's the technical disaster
and there's the the part where not a lot
of people care about the app
on the technical side
when i try to sign up i don't have an
iphone so i couldn't i couldn't i just
had to get on a beta
yeah a beta no on a waiting list for the
um
android beta
and so if you don't have an iphone
you're just out but even people with
iphones have said you know they're like
number 80 000 on the wait list and it
just doesn't go anywhere so there's like
the technical side
but also
what's the point of the app i mean what
i mean by that is
what they basically
market marketed as is you know all of
the stuff we can't say everywhere else
because it's disinformation and violates
terms of service you will be allowed to
say here so come here to say it but then
the problem is it's just a stupid echo
chamber and it's just the people that
spread the misinformation spreading it
to each other and then like journalists
who just want to see what's going on or
people like me who i'm like well it
sounds funny i'll try to sign up um but
uh so there's the technical problem and
the fact that not that many people are
interested in this so everything uh
everything going wrong
um if the preliminary traffic numbers
are of any indication
the former president and current wannabe
social media mogul
has a point about the uh low traffic the
daily beast reviewed analyses of visits
to truth social
and um
these are uh they describe the numbers
as anemic and that trump's truth social
is doing worse or the same as other maga
social sites like gab
getter
and uh then you've got rumble rumble
seems to actually be doing a little bit
better
but um it's not going particularly well
and i don't know as far as the waiting
list
how uh
even if everybody from the waiting list
got on it still doesn't seem like it
would be particularly successful so i
don't really pretend to know
what it would take to launch a real
bonafide competitor to like twitter
facebook youtube etc because i'm the
first to admit that you know there's
these network effects and so when we say
well if you don't like the rules on
youtube start your own fine sure we also
have to concede that once youtube has so
much market power it becomes more and
more difficult to really build something
successful as an alternative i
completely get that
but at the same time the the premise
here like this is where you go for your
right-wing stuff
that they call it for free speech where
you can say anything but you actually
can't like try criticizing trump on some
of these platforms you actually will get
will get banned but
you need to appeal to someone
other than those people
um in order to build a successful app
because the hardcore maga people that
are so hardcore
that they'll abandon twitter and
facebook for something like this it's a
relatively small crowd and so
it was clear what this was going to be
um there's other platforms trying to
fill the niche of like the hard right
maga clown type platform and it's
unlikely that this is going to succeed
my prediction it's very quietly
never spoken about they don't shut it
down because shutting it down would be
admitting defeat they just don't really
talk about it and if asked trump says
there's great interest and it's
continuing to build that's my prediction
let me know what you expect i want to
look at two very short clips here from
my pillow ceo and founder mike lindell
as i hope you know by now his
predictions are garbage
he was predicting in november and
december of 2020
that before january 6th the election
would flip to biden i'm sorry it would
flip to trump and it didn't and then
between january 6th and january 20th he
was predicting something would happen to
prevent joe biden from being inaugurated
and it didn't happen and then he
predicted it would happen in march april
and then it would be by the start of
summer and then the end of summer and
then by thanksgiving and then here we
are in march of 2022 when it hasn't
happened his new thing is
he will be filing a lawsuit to ban
all
voting machines i i know guys i know
take a listen to this you got a class
action lawsuit that's coming out
hopefully by next week we're getting uh
that's that's to
uh to make the machines it's a it's the
most important class action lawsuit in
american history in world history right
this is more important than
when companies leach leak toxic
chemicals into waterways and it causes
cancer
this is bigger than the class action
lawsuits against tobacco companies that
have led to so many deaths
this is the biggest come on get rid of
the machines because they're they're
considered defective devices that's what
the lawsuit is a defective product by
the way what does the claw suit mean
that brakes on a car brian when you get
a car and you're driving down the road
you expect to get you to point a to
point b if you turn to the right and it
goes left it's effective right well
we've been working on this lawsuit for
five months and um
and it's ready to launch we uh i've been
saying on my station uh braintv bring
speech tv
um
um we we reached seems confused by what
he's saying and out of breath i mean
every aspect of this is is cuckoo each
other call the county commissioners and
uh county clerks in the country to get
on board this class-action lawsuit we
have a list now of over 300 out of
that's out of 3000 counting what do you
think it's like to be so delusional
like what do you think it's like to be
so disconnected from reality
you only needed a couple but they're
jumping on board and uh so if you're
watching out there you guys can go to
frankspeach.com and go down there's a
forum there you fill out email my team
will uh you can get on board with this
what does it even mean to get on board
like if i want to get on board with his
lawsuit
if i go to what's even at frank's speech
um
yeah it's not even there's not really
even anything here like it's not even
clear you can do anything
um
just a complete and total fantasy world
i mean complete note that he also spoke
at a fundraiser for
um republican candidate carrie lake
and he talked about it there and here he
said it's a it's a lawsuit against all
machines
here um
i'm gonna tell you right now we're doing
i've been working on it five months yeah
and we're doing a class action you know
actually i'm announcing it here i
announced it on my program y'all watch
frankspeach.com
keep watching
um
um
but it's a class action lawsuit against
all machines
[Laughter]
that's just the that's even funnier
because i know he means voting machines
but when pillow says he's it's a he
your lot your your uh dishwasher
is about to be
uh legal hell is about to rain down on
your dishwasher
if you thought that your toaster was
free and clear
he is filing an injunction against the
toaster if you've been wondering why
isn't bagel mode working
he's suing he's suing over all machines
guys that they're defective devices okay
i have lawyers worked on this for five
months we're getting county
commissioners county clerks
they're all the plaintiffs and we've
already got about 300 on board
and we're going to get rid of these
machines once and for all oh good old
mike pillow he's simultaneously a
complete and total clown
but also a maga hero
and that's really uh kind of the same
thing we've got a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p here's a new
caller i have a feeling we might be
hearing from this guy frequently
yeah i listen to a show what a joke
right what a joke you need to wake up
have you been to a store lately yes
sales are empty
gas prices are doubled
inflation's at 31-year high i mean what
a joke you know i don't i know you don't
like trump okay that's good you don't
like delay tweet or you don't like what
he said about bleach i mean really grow
up be an adult he had his foot on
putin's neck
okay so there's i think
11 is
i'd have to go back i think there were
11 lies there
now you know i mean i've already spoken
about gas prices and
it's a real problem it's a problem in a
number of ways it just doesn't really
have to do with joe biden in north korea
under his thumb
what a joke really
you need to wake up
you and all your listeners you wake up
and you need to stop passing that
propaganda that democratic propaganda
you pass off his reality i'm not even a
democrat yeah we
think trump won well or at least he
would have won if there wasn't a
pandemic and you didn't bend those rules
in your favor so you could drop off
ballots have car loads of people pulling
up you know have people mailing in
millions and millions of ballots i think
we're up to
is it 18 lies so far we're only 51
seconds in but 18 lies yeah trump would
have won if you didn't cheat
and that's cheating
i don't know what you think cheating is
to be some grand conspiracy the green
conspiracy is democrats change the rules
yeah remember even uh republican
legislatures also uh modified uh voting
rules to allow people to vote uh vote by
mail who wouldn't ordinarily be allowed
to it doesn't really matter but again
this is a reminder there's people we can
talk to reasonably and there's people we
can't that guy seems to be beyond saving
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will actually talk about the
joe biden approval rating bump that
happened is it ukraine is it the state
of the union what is it we will talk
about u.s olympic champion brittany
griner being arrested and held in russia
and we will talk about a man sentenced
to prison for using the covet loan money
that he got to buy pokemon cards pokemon
cards all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show i have some coveted
money fraud stories to tell myself not
of anything i did but just of things
i've caught wind of um sign up at
jointpakman.com get instant access to
the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the nebia by moan
quattro is the world's most advanced
shower head it only uses 50 percent as
much water but with a super high
pressure spray click the link below and
use the code pacman for 10 percent off
all nebia products